alors les scieries aujourd'hui
normalement dû rue roland garros ouais
ouais ouais wayoro et roland garros eh
bien je vais vous dire on va faire un
petit jeu on va chronométrés vous pouvez
faire service voilà coup droit cuillère
tout ce que vous voulez d'accord il ya
une machine pour chronométrer celui qui
fera la balle la plus rapide
c'est la balle chronométrés la plus
puissante désignera celui qui sera
déguisé en andre agassi toutes les
missions andre agassi de l'époque
voyez avec la feria comme ça du coup
voilà d'accord nuc ont regardé à la
regarder
voilà moi je vous dis tout de suite si
c'est moi qui gagne ce sera je préfère
le dire voilà moi je préfère est à la
botte
voilà je sais c'est moi qui gagne 2 sera
répond alors ce que je propose c'est que
vous commenciez on va démarrer par la
reine du tennis
bien entendu allez je sais j'ai ggg
aulas pas mal a tonné combien c'est pas
branché batterie bas valais c'est pas
honte à vue j'adore parce qu'ils se
qualifient cet âge ils se cassent
moustache sa grand-mère à des boosters
être bon
oui gros 58 quotas les retraites en ahl
de chance tu as la chance mais c'est pas
mal de kilomètres heure ah ouais il a dû
mettre miles roma km/heure aux
surveillants on va leur faire puisque la
séance ont intrigué rosbif la roumanie
bah voilà est arrivé alors qu'à ben oui
c'est sûr ça marche vraiment ce jeu là
non c'est une femme et toi tu vas faire
connaître la richesse
ah là là un problème si l'action
céréales ex merci tout cas c'est un très
beau début d'émission
mais bon c'est juste un 14 km géraldine
tu obtiens ton chi absolument 74 km à
l'est on ira regarder cette puissance
falala déjà mais j ai pas mal avant tout
son pack aussi la méfiance ou tel mais
[Rires]
j'essaie de m'améliorer 63 est pas mal
mais là c'est impossible refait le bien
63 mais d'où ce sont trois voilà
cinquante sept avec ces dernières
géraldine merci en tout cas tu as l'air
super bien ajouté d'histoire médaille va
vous qui avait très mal aux dents hier
d'ailleurs je vous le dis pour faire une
des balles on a pris une de ces dons
allez vas-y bénin et de cours de couy
59,53 oui carrément
il a très peur vraiment il a très peu
mais bon allez merci à nous frapper les
championnats c'est super on dirait que
ça pèse 5 kg par rapport au badminton
si on n'est déjà fait des amis sous les
amener le soin que l'on raconte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
emad tout peuple a l'air pas de paul
savage en ébauche juriste avant ce but
[Musique]
allait battre allez vas-y attention tu
vas te fais c'est mamie walhalla mais
ces deux fronts les ans au mois dans le
vert allez vas-y vas-y vas-y on se
retrouve sans river il ya quelques
paniers api voudrais bien vous y
retournez la non merci pas de travail
rémo alors je suis tombé bas jimmy
vasser jamais briser il m'a dit
aujourd'hui c'est mon chéri dont semble
bien que l'économie voit son séjour a
dit le roi il n'est pas sûr qu'elle
accroît 19 avril faisant une 2e - chérie
tu amérique a été blessé censure disent
bravo je me verrai mon palace temps ces
gens me qui va être dur très solide il
est très solide jean mimi les saints
sportif un jour me ne croyait pas à pas
mal 85 moi vous avez joué au tennis dans
le camion il va faire trop chaud alors
vous le dis moi je vous le dit c'est
raymond qui en fait si je fais plus que
114 handball c'est sûr que je vais
déguisé raymond est ce qu'on a essayé
vous attendez vous à ce que tu peux
donner ta question
on les attendait non au ballon c'est
encore plus risqué bah oui mais c'est
bon on est on est on amène quelques uns
du but lui qu'on n'a pas envie qu'il
soit malade
merci il a une bonne prise déjà énorme
et nous c'est un grand joueur garde
comme les grands six migrants illégaux
à des courses à alexandrie en à
professionnels scène je sers trop fort
mais non mais c'est ça on peut hélas il
serait bon pour les affaires
oh là là sans casse grâce à lucas bravo
me faisant une deuxième a dit monsieur
sylla et élégant mais il est très
élégant et révèle tout
4 mais c'est moi est ce que ça ne vous
étonne pas à chaque fois qu'il ya
quelqu'un d'extérieur qui vient ton
appart fois alors vous êtes des bras
cassés comme jamais on n'a vu ou bien
les gens sont des génies les posez vous
les bonnes questions tellement mais il
joue il aima ibookstore gala il est
temps sur l'a34 134 c'est un dur
d'accord ça marche tu choisiras tirait
bien sur bastia pacy rigole pas c'est
serré c'est son domaine en 34 c'est
beaucoup beaucoup plus 34 et de son
attente en ça marche ce n'était pas
malin y avait au moins deux sont je suis
pas bien enfin les billets par 2,2 sur
sept ans ah ça c'est pas bizarre aulas
est reparti en maille là c'est pas
cadrée à plus de 106 106
allez j'ai choisir bas regarde je me
tourner je veux choisir mais il
s'appelle jambiers et glisse à peine
maquillée
non je pense que je choisirais le tacot